do you know how to hack do you know how
to program do you even know how to DDoS
do you even know how to run a script do
you even know how to hack the matrix do
you even know how to [ __ ] a grandma god
dammit well if you do you're in luck
pewdiepie legend of the brofist is
hackable there's a glitch that we left
in the game and if you can discover it
you will win it's an exclusive 3d
printed and painted statue of legend of
the brofist I will sign these and send
them out myself
alright we got five of them first five
that phone's to glitch winch the glitch
will be available for everyone on 1st of
April but after that you got to show how
it's done now what is this glitch all
about
I'll show you baby it's time to hack
I hate 85
ah we're in this is big by legend of the
brofist hack mo [ __ ] yes
holy [ __ ] it's like I'm on drugs
it's my hand shaking or am i doing jazz
hands I can't tell the difference what
what is going on man I don't even know I
just ah ah forget it
fell Ricky ah what the [ __ ] is this
I have no idea hey boss we contained him
Hey
what [ __ ] yes god damn that's terrifying
Jack calm down oh so everything is
random that happens in the in the glitch
so you really never know what's going to
happen out of mines to spend a lot of
time updating this game for free and as
a things for everyone supporting the
game and the game is just getting better
and better so if you haven't checked out
the game yet what are you waiting for
there's so much fun to to have in this
game not too much fun just the right
amount appropriate amount of fun oh god
I forgot it was a way wearing this way
weights going backwards what the [ __ ]
we're going the wrong way we're going
the wrong way man oh my god this is so
trippy what the [ __ ] is this I can't
even see anything oh my god Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] is this
barrels are missing up the game it seems
the paddles are messing up the game
no it's time to get the hacking on how
much money do you have hate money money
all right press this is so cool I love
this game check it out please do support
me and the developer like we'd really
appreciate it like it's in the
description go hack go hack right now
remember there's a signed is thing as a
reward show me that you're the number
one hacker I believe in you
all right Bruce thank you so much for
watching this video if you enjoyed leave
a like as always really appreciate it
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you both in the next video stay
awesome still be a sad loose I'm kidding
don't worry ah we love you know we don't
okay so here's the new level love is in
the air we're standing out while playing
here so we can dance do you want
let's not no we're not